[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing all of the memories
that we see through the pensive in Harry
Potter rare and Powerful the majority of
pensives are typically quite small
devices that due to their incredibly
personal nature are often kept on one's
person of course one very notable
exception of this is the large pensive
located in the headmaster's office at
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry this pensive is used to store
all the school's Headmasters memories so
that their predecessors may watch and
learn from them it's described as large
ornate ancient and made entirely out of
stone with Engravings of modified sacks
and rooms etched all over it it is also
said to be so old that some witches and
wizards believe that the hardcore
expensive predates even the school's
Castle to use a pensive one needs only
to extract a memory and deposit it into
the pensive's Basin give it a stir and
immerse oneself into the memory often
described described as wispy or gossamer
and appearance memories in this form are
believed to be neither liquid nor solid
and are used as described by Albus
Dumbledore in the following passage one
simply siphons the excess thoughts from
one's mind pause them into the Basin and
examines them at one slasher it becomes
easy to spot patterns and links you
understand when they're in this form as
readers of the books will recall the
pensive was used quite frequently
throughout the series after its
introduction in the fourth novel The
Goblet of Fire in the films however it
shows up substantially less so in honor
of the new HBO Max reboot of the series
that was recently announced I've decided
to share with you all of the pensive
memories from the original novels let's
Dive Right In 1. Dumbledore's memory of
the Death Eater trials the majority of
the memories that Harry experiences
through the pensive belong to Alba
stumbledore and this first one is no
exception one of our very first
introductions to the pensive this memory
is about the Death Eater trials that
took place after Voldemort had fallen
from power in 1981. in the memory we are
made privy to the fact that Igor
karkaroff the Headmaster of durmstrang
Institute during Harry's fourth year at
Hogwarts Bellatrix Lestrange brothers
rodolfus and rabbistan Lestrange and
Barty Crouch Jr were all trying for
their crimes as Death Eaters in the
1980s 2. Dumbledore's memory of Bertha
jawkins yet another Dumbledore memory
the Pens have allowed Harry to learn
more about Bertha jawkins a missing
witch who was also a Ministry of magic
employee working in the department of
magical games and sports at the time of
her disappearance the memory shows
Bertha well before she went missing as a
16 year old Hogwarts student who had
been hexed by one of her peers
3. Dumbledore's memory of Snape's dark
mark for Harry there was no arguing that
Professor Sever's name should not be
trusted a feeling he felt all the more
fervently after seeing Dumbledore's
memory of Snape's dark mark in this
memory we see sephorus tell Dumbledore
that his dark mark the mark on his arm
that branded him a Death Eater was
indeed returning
4. Dumbledore's memory of trelawny's
real Prophecy in the Order of the
Phoenix Harry once again finds himself
immersed in one of Dumbledore's memories
within the pensive this time the
memories of Dumbledore's interview with
Sipple trelawny in which the real reason
she was hired is the school's divination
Professor becomes clear while being
interviewed by Dumbledore the Hogs head
end in hogsmeade the future Professor
breaks off and begins speaking
differently almost as if in a trance and
provides a true prophecy that there will
be a chosen one the one with the power
to Vanquish the dark lord approaches
born to those who have Thrice to find
him born as the seventh month dies and
the Dark Lord will Mark him as his equal
but he will have power the Dark Lord
knows not and either must die at the
hand of the other for neither can live
while the other survives the one with
the power to Vanquish the Dark Lord will
be born as the seventh month dies 5.
gratic Sparks memory of maripi gaunt
this is the first time that we get a
glimpse into someone's mind other than
Dumbledore
as the memory belonged to the owner of
Borgen and Berks the antique Wizarding
Shop with a questionable reputation
located down Nocturne alley in this
memory character's Burke recalls maripi
gaunt Voldemort's mother selling him
slytherin's locket which he only paid a
mere 10 gallons for taking advantage of
her ignorance and Desperation at this
point marapi had been left by Tom Riddle
senior and was heavily pregnant with
their unborn child the Future Dark Lord
6. Dumbledore's memory of meeting young
Tom Riddle this memory is yet another of
Albus Dumbledore's here he shows Harry
his first meeting with the child version
of Tom Riddle long before he became
Voldemort the memory reveals the first
interactions between Dumbledore and the
young Tom while he was living at wool's
orphanage a muggle institution located
in London 7. Bob Ogden's memory of the
gaunts Bob Ogden was a Ministry official
who at one point in his career visited
the decrepit heart of the gaunt family
located just outside of the Village of
little hangleton there to attempt to
arrest Morphin gaunt for hexing
unsuspecting Muggles in this memory Bob
Ogden meets with morphin's father
marvolo and his sister marapi instead
eight Morphin gaunt's memory of meeting
teenage Tom Riddle this memory is from
the perspective of morphine gaunt Tom
Riddle's unknowing Uncle here we learned
that it was an adolescent Tom who not
only stole the gaunt family heirloom of
the peveral ring but also murdered the
entire riddle family his family who
still lived nearby the gaunt's ancestral
home in little hangleton after killing
his father and grandparents Voldemort
framed his uncle Morphin for the crime
who spent the remainder of his life in
Azkaban 9. slughorn's memory of Tom
Riddle and horcruxes this is one of the
most well-known memories that Harry
reviews in the pensive in his attempts
to help Dumbledore uncover what dark
magic Tom Riddle was after while a
student at Hogwarts there are actually
two versions of this memory that we see
the first being a badly tampered one
that Professor Slughorn attempted to
alter and the second being the real
memory a memory of an exchange between
the professor and Tom in the actual
memory it's revealed that Tom approached
Professor Slughorn and asked him about
Hall cruxes and how to make multiple of
them despite his apparent discomfort on
the topic Slughorn shares with Tom what
he knows 10. hoki's memory of Tom Riddle
in this memory for the first time Harry
experiences that the pensive can show
one memories from magical beings other
than just witches and wizards here he's
immersed in the house self's memory by
the name of hoki Hokie belonged to an
older wedge named HEB siba Smith and in
the memory the house elf recalls
Voldemort stealing hufflepuff's cup and
how the dark lord murdered absiber and
framed hokey for it 11. Dumbledore's
memory of Voldemort's interview the last
of Dumbledore's memories for us to cover
today it's another memory of an
interview that Dumbledore conducted for
a position at Hogwarts this time however
the interview was with a wizard who did
not get the job Voldemort the scene
shows a version of an older Tom Riddle
whose appearance has already begun to
resemble that of Voldemort in the memory
he has supposedly come to apply for the
open position at Professor for defense
against the dark arts of course what
becomes clear is that he never intended
to get the role rather he uses the
opportunity to curse the position in
perpetuity which is the reason no Dana
Professor ever lasted more than a year
after that he then went on to hide one
of his horcruxes ravenclaws died him in
the Castle's room of requirements 12.
Severus name's memories of Lily Evans
perhaps I spoke too soon when I
mentioned Professor slughorn's memories
of Tom Riddle and the horcrux has been
well-known memories Harry experiences in
the pensive when in actual fact these
memories of Snape's are likely the most
well known in a complex Montage of
memories Harry finally gets to see who
Severus Snape really was discovering
that the only thing it ever truly
motivated him was his love for Harry's
mother Lily we see scenes of the two
meeting for the first time as children
growing up together in the Muggle town
of cokeworth we see their friendship
Blossom over their shared ability to do
magic we see them go to Hogwarts and get
sorted into different houses we see them
drift apart and ultimately we see Lily
choose the boy who bullied Severus for
years James Potter and Severus choose
Voldemort Snape lashes out and calls her
a mud blood lily gives him an ultimatum
their friendship or the dark arts he
chooses the dark arts and his daddy to
friends then finally we see Snape give
Voldemort the prophecy about the chosen
one only to realize in horror that it
had pointed the dark lord directly to
the woman he loves from childhood to
adult good Snape's memories of his time
spent with or in discussion of Lily show
why he was ultimately devoted to
Dumbledore and against Voldemort the
dark lord murdered the love of his life
and with that we've come to the end of
another video what did you think do you
remember all of these pensive memories
do you hope that they'll all be included
in the upcoming television adaptation of
Harry Potter please share your thoughts
in the comments below and as always if
you enjoyed this video don't forget to
like it and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live